[Music]  foreign  the great Doom is coming  [Music]  the sins of the father are heaped upon  the sun  you have no clue the power this book  possesses  I know those who seek it mean to do the  city harm  before it can be truly saved Gotham  must be burned to the ground  Talking Dead folks reptile plagues it's  not natural  Spirit we come to us now I can't pretend  to know exactly what I'm about to face  but I do know  I must stop it  we meaning to give this city purpose and  honor the damnation for it  Mercy  what did this what's happening to you  what needs to happen  who's way to die  and under become his City savior  [Music]  hello Bruce you can't be  [Music]  [Music]